[Music]
hey good hi last time I got to talk to
you or you were dancing up storm
you're doing fine leave it off we'll get
to that in a second okay let's start
with this it's this is exciting
yes it's been a busy morning for you
already yeah how did this come your way
how did the opportunity present itself
to you um my manager yeah my manager
just came to me and said they're
offering you there where were you when
you found out Africa
you were right Africa so you've kind of
relocated here to America for this yes
yes I'm living in Africa right now so I
came back in just for this and yeah I
wasn't really I wasn't sure I wasn't
sure if I should do it but it's always
been my favorite show so there was
always that part of me that's like you
know you want to do it you've been a fan
yes all right every season very very
good so you're in Africa is that where
they're playing like a lot of these days
no no I'm doing what my charity out
there animal adventures is my
organization through so doing all
charity stuff working with the animals
and wildlife in conservation
thank you sir if I wasn't all right good
for you that's great work thank you no
it's awesome it's fun
very good so you're coming on to this I
know you're no stranger to a reality
television what is your biggest fear
your biggest concern about having these
cameras on you non-stop 24/7 today um
well I mean I guess I think the the fear
with the cameras is just that you forget
that you're always on camera and maybe
you do something like that should be
done in right you know like like
basically like most of our lives no you
have to go into the bathroom to change
clothes or blow your nose they're doing
anything awkward oh yeah yeah I mean and
then you're gonna be seen without makeup
all the time and you're not gonna be
looking your best and you just kind of
have to accept it it it it that's very
good yeah yeah you definitely at some
point I mean this is a little bit of a
truncated version of the the show that
you know we've seen but at some point
you do just have to kind of give into a
rut yeah so what's like the bottom line
things that you
doing like blow your nose on camera I
you know what I don't like that in
public I don't like people do it all the
time like I guess that's a pet peeve for
me I don't like when unless it's just so
bad it's like where people are like
please just blow your nose and stops
theirs
okay so you're gonna have to be confined
in a house with these other celebrities
for obviously weeks no phone no contact
outside yeah I'm already feeling that it
sounds so simple and it's like it's such
a reasoning on paper you know what
you're so used to reaching for your
phone and checking your messages and
if you forget to do something you do it
and right now there's things that I keep
remembering I'm like I didn't do that
and now I can't do it and what do I do
like I I needed to send this email or I
need to connect this person or I needed
to like fix this mm-hmm that's really
hard then you gotta wait a while before
you do it it's really hard like right
now too cuz we're in sequester in this
hotel and there's no sound you're just
sitting in silence on the topic what are
you doing yourself what do you do with
your mind in that thing are you
well I mean I've been sleeping a lot
because I didn't sleep the night before
trying to get everything done that I
needed to do Louie literally didn't go
to sleep so the minute they left me
alone yesterday I just fell asleep and
they kept calling and needing me to do
stuff so then I would do it and then I
go back to sleep and I kept saying I
kind of get up because I won't sleep
tonight and then they said we had to be
up and ready so early I'm like oh good
I'm going back to sleep back now I'm
trying to think back on Dancing with the
Stars how competitive are you I mean
this is you know it's a competition here
yeah I'm super competitive but I I'm
also very where it's not good to win
everything in this you don't want to
appear that strong see here's the thing
being a fan you know some strategies you
know what to try and do what not to do
so let's talk a little bit about that
you know why is it not good to win
everything if you're too strong you're
gonna be a target they're gonna go for
you first so it doesn't mean I don't
necessarily want to win the first HOH
I'm gonna evaluate it see who's in there
and see how I feel and who's left you
know if I want to draw
or whatever it may be but um I think
every situation is different and you
don't want to be a target and there's
multiple ways to try to fade into the
background a little bit
lay low not seem like you know if the
big strong guys there's a reason they
always go first it's a reason in this
game they get targeted first because
they just look intimidating and if you
look at the winners traditionally it's
not the big strong guy that wins you
know it's it's somebody who's got good
social game as somebody who's good with
their mind and they have good memory
and they're decent at competitions it's
good to have a mixture
you are so locked in you are so well
versed I'm impressed I mean you know do
you know this show you know what your
strategy is you can stick to it
yes so get off that's very that's very
impressive okay how I mean you are you
ready to be on camera all you non-stop
well you seem like you're okay with it
you guys you've got your strategy you
know what you want to do what you won't
do
yeah but I mean I mean I don't know if
you ever feel ready like are you ever
ready but I mean I'm so excited to go in
and to play this game and I have been
prepping for it for a while and I mean I
kind of can't wait until Wednesday to
get in there and get going so in
nonsense yeah I'm ready
you look Jack he looks like now shifting
gears a little bit here
you know romantically there's been you
know obviously show manses there's my
are you in a position where that could
be a possibility for you honestly don't
think anybody's gonna have a show he has
this season Joe no no I don't I look I'm
in a relationship I'm very happy yes
it's not part of my game plan I gotta go
and showmance makes you a target as well
so I don't think it's good game play
anyway
but I mean you've got a group of celebs
that are somewhat older I think and
wiser and probably are in relationships
and we're only in there like a month so
it's just not good game play how do you
know this loves you're someone older I
would like I mean you're absolutely how
you know you're supposed to yeah I've
got my ideas you've got your idea I've
seen things that have gone out there
here in their hints and I've seen all
the list of people guessing and I've got
a pretty good idea I think at least half
of who I think I know is right there so
strategic and so locked in and tune into
well how you want
I mean it's it's fun to see something
that's such a big fan of the show of
being able to kind of dive into the
middle of it obviously that was a big
part of the the reason that you want to
do it alright how are you because be a
little tricky on this yeah well I'm
vegan and I'm gluten free oh boy so that
does make it challenging now I have some
ideas with the slop though I do have
some some really good plans for that and
part of me wants that experience anyway
I you know you're not in Big Brother if
you haven't been on slop once so I'm
hoping I'm kind of hoping for that
because that's just part of the
challenge and I think part of this game
is seeing how far you can push yourself
what can you achieve and what when
you're on the spot and you're in so much
pain
what what will your body do what will
your mind do what's your decision I mean
when you're going for lots of of money
or prestige or just you want to win
whatever it is that drives you what can
you achieve and you've been you know
like I say you're no stranger to that
talking about pushing yourself Dancing
with the Stars lots of challenges people
say it's one of the hardest things
they've ever done what do you think is
going to be tougher this experience or
your experience I think this is gonna be
way tougher not even close not even
close this will be way tougher it's
you're you're constantly on you're
constantly
emotionally gonna be drained thinking
about the game all the time you can't
let your guard down even for a second so
whether it's physical drainage whether
it's mental mental emotional I mean
you're gonna go through everything here
so well speed or not letting your guard
down you're no stranger to having a
poker face did you think that experience
I mean is that gonna help you out a
little bit I think that I think that my
poker experience will help me in reading
people I think reading them in the
situation and I think my acting is my
poker face as well because you good
that's right I'm gonna go in there I'm
gonna play a character people think it's
us and it's the real us but I'm playing
a character you might see the real me in
the diary room cuz then I'll be telling
you what I'm doing out there but what
I'm doing out there what I'm doing in
the diary room may be very very
you are so locked in let's talk about
your character and tell me you know I my
strategy has got to keep forming and
changing and going with the house so
good appending on what I'm given I will
have to shift gears a lot so you haven't
actually locked in your your your
character yeah I think other words you
don't know the persona until you sort of
get to feel the world to some degree I
mean look I know that I I don't want to
be one of these loud type-a
personalities so look I'm I'm very OCD
in Taipei and like all of that in real
life and my character is not my
character there needs to sit back not
being in the forefront of every
conversation not be the one talking
maybe be the one that's asking questions
letting the other people talk let might
get to know them have a good social game
but let the other people be the ones
talking about themselves and their
family and whatever and why they're
there give me information and that's
that's like part of my character and let
them fight and just sit back and watch
and listen and let them fight and let
them all start to get mad at each other
and then I'm just another vote that can
help you get to the end and I'll make my
little alliances and some will be hidden
and some will be public maybe but I mean
that's kind of my my general right now
plan of going in CBS showed some images
of the house do you have you seen those
yes what do you think of some of the
things that sort of stand down you get
the square table we've got the espresso
machine your own bed yes you could sleep
in your own bed yes then don't you
taking what you see I mean it's
beautiful
yeah it's amazing the house is always
amazing I love the decor and the colors
and they always change it up I think is
very cool I mean I've got to tell you my
favorite part about Big Brother is the
editing they edit it together so
flawlessly and I don't know how they can
do 294 cameras or whatever it is but
they get these moments and the sound
effects they put to the moments and the
music and like some people had their own
theme music so every time they walked
the screen like evil dick you'd get this
like theme music I mean it's genius
that's what makes the show for me like I
will sit there and watch it with my
boyfriend be like did you hear the music
do you hear do you see what they're
doing cuz they can build something so
well yeah and I think it's gonna be so
weird to be in there because I imagine
it's very quiet I imagine we're sitting
in silence and we only hear each other
to screw so that's gonna be like all
right so let me ask you this yeah I know
you've been doing a little bit of your
recon and you think you know who's gonna
be in there who who are some celebrities
or a celebrity that you would love to
have in the house with you okay I picked
somebody that would be great in the
house is Neil Patrick Harris cuz he's he
knows the game he's very smart he would
be somebody great to align with I think
we have different strengths and we both
know the game we're both big fans and so
if he's in there right off the bat I'm
grabbing him nice who's a celebrity that
you really hope it's not out of the way
maybe some of the names that you've seen
I am NOT gonna say I mean that's
probably just way this I'll say this if
if there's anybody in the house who's
played before then I don't think that's
quite fair okay there have been some
names that of people that have played
before and whether they played here or
in the UK or anywhere I would like to
see that it's an even playing field for
all of us that have not played this game
before so let's let's do it all together
for the first time okay that's fair to
say let's first say yeah obviously we
talked a little bit about dance with
stars people that do reality shows
there's benefits that come to it you get
more exposure you get more opportunities
after you finish the show what are you
hoping that you get from this experience
I'm really hoping that I get exposure
for the animals in Africa that's really
why I decided to do this my nonprofit
animal Avengers and a new initiative
we're doing called rhino review where
we're hoping that we can raise awareness
of what's happening with the poaching
crisis and get more people involved in
conservation so that's really why I'm
doing it
[Music]